Hello Freak bitches.
I can't wait to see it.
Do you,
do you like now that you have this gigantic audience,
do you feel certain amount of responsibility?
Yeah,
it was half intellectual integrity is the most important thing.
And the great thing about this and the great thing about the way the Internet
works is that,
I mean,
look at the,
look at the people who are at the top.
Look at it like something like Pewdie Pie.
[inaudible] man of outstanding moral character.
He,
do you know him?
Do you hang with them?
I've spoken to him a few times,
but I don't need to hang with them to know,
look at what he does.
He doesn't go around bullying people.
Doesn't go around lying about people.
It doesn't eat.
You guys aren't doing charity and being like,
Hey Bros,
you know,
and being nice to people and being inspiration.
What happened with him?
Can you,
would you go,
okay,
well let's,
let's go over the actual,
this is,
by the way,
this is affected me and affected a lot of youtube people where their youtube
videos used to have,
um,
much freer monetization.
Meaning that for people listening,
say if Sargon puts out a youtube video,
you could have ads on that youtube video and your youtube videos get a lot of
downloads,
man.
I mean it would be very lucrative for you.
Yeah.
And then with us,
our youtube money was cut by more than 60%
to retain 40% of your income was pretty good as well.
Yeah.
Well the old anything controversial,
anything having to do with anything,
right wing is deemed not s not friendly for advertising.
Anything that has drugs in the title is deemed not friendly for advertising.
It's like we've literally been able to change the title of things and re upload
them and then the ads they accepted just,
yeah,
so the same content.
So what all this came from is Pooty pie who has an enormous youtube presence,
right?
Doesn't he have like 50 million followers?
Right.
Holy Shit.
And,
and he made some videos that the,
what is it,
the Washington Post?
Cause I would,
it was Wall Street Journal.
Wall Street Journal.
Can I tell you about it?
Please do.
Because you,
I'm sure much I got,
I did a bunch of videos on this and it was the funniest thing in the world.
I love the language they used as well.
What's a scoop?
A scoop is a new story that other people are not aware of yet.
You got it first.
So if uh,
if tens of millions of people have seen something and then if I'm a wolf street
journalist and I come along and I find something with tens of millions of people
who've seen,
can I rightly call that a scoop?
Well you can definitely call it a news story and you could definitely say that
people in see that.
This goes back to what we were talking about before,
whereas they have a hierarchy of viewership.
Like what,
what is,
what is a,
a real network?
What does a real newspaper,
what is real journalism like in their mind,
I'm sure the Wall Street Journal considers themselves to be in the hierarchy
versus someone who has helped,
but they don't have 55 million downloads.
They don't,
I mean,
there's no way if the w if know the Wall Street Journal puts out a video couple
million.
Yeah.
If they put out a video,
if they got a Wii,
a million hits on their video,
that would be a big deal.
Yeah,
that'd be thrilled.
If Pooty pie on only a million hits,
I'm one of these videos,
he'll be super depressed.
He is a much bigger entity than them.
But in their mind,
like a scoop is them the legitimate media.
So pointing out something in the illegitimate,
this new weird,
the CTO Lagos' fear.
Yeah.
So basically PD pie,
he's a comedian and he makes jokes,
but he's uh,
like I said,
he's a man of good character and he's parents should be thanking Cutie Pie for
being the person he is because he's talking to their kids and their kids are
gonna grow up being decent people because of his influence.
But the Wall Street Journal,
Ben Fritz and Rolfe Winkler and there was another one,
I can't remember his name at the moment.
They decided what they were going to do is,
and I don't know who put them up to this obviously,
but they,
they're going to watch about six months of his video,
go through and find any antisemitic jokes that he had made.
Well,
I mean by definition is a joke.
So there's not six months.
Yeah,
six,
eight.
They sat together a video every day and they got about under like two minutes of
footage or something with him making jokes at the expense of the Nazis
effectively.
And they were like,
well this guy's promoting antisemitism to see those jokes.
Cause I've heard about them.
I don't know the actual jokes that he said that they were saying,
but,
but here's the point.
Let's get to it.
They were saying that he is making light of being a Nazi or pretending to be a
Nazi and that this is what's fucked up.
Like he was promoting antisemitism by parodying.
The Nazis tried to explain to people as hard as Hogan's heroes work,
there isn't a Mel Brooks a bit.
Yeah,
bit of an old antique Jesus Christ.
He must be.
Yeah.
Oh God.
Just,
you know,
I mean,
springtime for Hitler,
you could say was somehow or another humanizing,
I imagine to created a lot of Nazis can imagine if somebody argument made the
argument that Mel Gibson created Nazis.
That's how far we've come.
Milberg Mel Brooks.
Mel Gibson.
Yeah,
he might.
Well,
today
that was clearly a Friday and all they ever ask you about when someone says,
Mel Gibson drunk,
I think of him yelling about Jews and cops.
That's all a big bid and everything's crazy.
Fucking Jews.
See Jesus smells,
Jesus smell,
dude.
Let's get right poster boy,
right?
Yeah.
Well he is,
well,
he's a serious like nine 11 and
conspiracy the lever and yeah,
where's that Charlie Sheen?
Oh,
probably lumping them together,
but got my pain.
The,
these,
these videos.
I'm,
one of them was the funniest thing because they were taking like,
you know,
the jokes were like,
like I'm there,
like 20 seconds of joke taken out like a 10 minute video,
you know,
where he's just,
it's just like a cutaway to it,
you know,
skit,
uh,
you know,
Wah Wah.
I'm like,
you know what?
One of them was a joke about how the media takes his jokes out of context to try
and frame him as something new.
Right,
and they cut that out of context and used it and it was just like,
well that is it.
Which is amazing.
It's incredible.
It's amazing that they had the balls to do it and they would,
they would not only be proud of what they did.
They called it a scoop and then they went to advertisers and said,
look at this hate speech,
but how did they get away with doing that?
No one can lend them to how come no one from the Wall Street Journal sat them
down and said,
well listen,
this is definitely not him saying that you're going to take something out of
context and then doing it.
Is it because of it is and then you took it out of context and did exactly what
he's saying you shouldn't do.
That's kind of crazy.
It's mental.
It is mental.
It's absolutely it's,
but they feel like they can get away with it because they're in the hallowed
halls of actual media and they're putting this stuff out there.
JVC,
you define it,
see it,
see what you can be.
The terms of the jokes that Pooty pie said there were supposedly the,
the funny thing though is if you look at the numbers,
they look like that.
The Wall Street Journal,
if you look at his numbers,
they look like that.
What's so strange?
He's making hand gestures down for the Wall Street Journal up for Pooty Pie.
And what?
What's so strange about it though is that Peter Pan isn't that competition.
All right,
here we go.
Here we go.
Let's play with some of them.
Great.
Let's see what we got here.
My name is Pia.
Whoa.
Okay.
So Dan,
27 year old,
but known as PD pot
playing video games on Youtube.
Typical Nazis.
Okay.
53 million subscriber.
You still 55 now Jesus.
The biggest star on the site by far the stories.
Oh No,
that's best scoop.
It's better.
Let's get into the latest scoop.
So it's him.
This is the,
I think this is the one recently,
some of his videos are brief including Nazi messages,
images of
Adolf Hitler and explicit antisemitic commentary.
So this is the Washington Post's version and we'll strip street the Wall Street
Journal rather sorry.
Following a request for comment from the Wall Street Journal.
Disney said the videos are inappropriate and cut ties to Pooty pie who ran his
business cost of millions of dollars of Disney subsidiary maker studios cost
Pooty pie millions in a January 11th video,
Mr Blah blah blah,
featured two men holding assigned reading death to all Jews after hiring them
more freelance website.
I liked the editing.
See the joke is his reaction to the fact that you could subscribe to Kim Star
who was like a another big youtube,
but he's mocking them.
I don't think they would actually do it.
I feel partially responsible but just I didn't think they would.
It might just be my sense of crude,
sense of humor,
but I think there's something funny about that.
And I don't fire the media for miss characterizing him about,
again,
I think there's a difference between a joke and actual like
fucking death to all Jews.
If I made a video saying,
hey guys,
uh,
Peter Pie here,
death to all Jews,
I want you to say after me death to all Jews.
And um,
you know,
Hitler was right.
I really opened my eyes to why power and I think it's time that we did something
about it.
That's essentially how they're reporting this as if that's what I was saying or
some shit like that.
Well,
it's amazing how popular it is with such a shitty grasp of English.
He's Swedish.
Apologies.
Can camouflage messages that may still be received and celebrated by hate
groups.
The southern poverty law center says,
yeah.
So if,
if the southern poverty law center condemns you,
it's becoming a bit of a badge of honor these days.
In the video since removed,
he posted a video of a man dressed as Jesus Christ.
I love how they have like since removed is bold and then Jesus Christ is really
nice guy.
The Jesus guy.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
You only want it to act upon.
God's will.
Don't worry though.
He stands beside God now he isn't.
Wait,
that's all folks Jesus out.
And I wasn't the one who made him say in or was it?
No,
it wasn't.
I don't think so.
He set up a go fund me page and his own website.
So you can take orders from Jesus himself.
And also,
can I just point out
this is not what I'm looking for.
Where,
where are the actual videos of him doing the,
the Nazi shit?
That was it.
That's 100% it is their article that led to all of this.
Yeah.
Right.
But what we're looking at here,
this is the Wall Street Journal's version of it.
Yeah.
So this is,
these are the clips that they said,
this is the actual clips that they're saying are the thing that shows him to be
antisemetic.
Holy Shit.
The most of it was,
I thought it was way better.
I mean there and I thought it was just a little video he got made off Fiverr.
Yeah,
it's just him prancing around on the Internet.
It's just,
it's just silly childish jokes and it's obviously,
I mean,
how many Nazis do you think this made?
Three.
Really?
That's how I got to say hi.
This is so stupid.
It's like you don't,
it doesn't take a lot to like turn them.
There was the really bad thing about this though is the fact that they didn't
put this article out until they had like taken these clips and dumped him into
Disney and Disney.
Disney obviously new shit.
There's going to be a shit storm about this.
Why are they drawn to do this?
Let's go attack.
But why?
What is it?
Cause losing money is politics and politics as well.
Yeah.
He marks like,
you know,
he mocks feminism.
He knows mocks social justice.
He's not,
he's not,
he's a liberal.
He's not a progressive.
That's the difference.
Why would they think that they could just do that though?
Because they've got the power to do that.
No one can stop them.
You couldn't,
but they did.
It cost him millions of dollars.
I'm sure they did.
But now costing them their reputation.
I'm salinity.
Yeah.
I mean you can't just do that street journals.
They,
they took a big hit from this.
I'm sure that unbelievably arrogant.
Well actually you,
it's really interesting,
right?
There was a off after all of this shit,
so blue over there was a bunch of polls done of like 13 to 18 year olds and it
was really,
really fascinating how um,
you had like favorability and how well known things where and like youtube was
really well known,
really favorable with kids,
you know?
And then you had the Wall Street Journal,
which was really well known but really unfavorable with kids.
How do,
how the kids know what the Wall Street generalists because of Pewdie Pie.
So now they strict with the Wall Street Journal and this why the millions of
people that are his fans.
Exactly.
Well that's a big mistake to a guy with a platform like that in 10 years time
when the voters and the were reading and consuming news,
the Wall Street Journal will continue to be that.
They'll continue to go down.
Pierre Dupont's still be doing well.
But what's the,
what's crazy is I never thought of the Wall Street Journal.
Is that what I thought of the Wall Street Journal as being like informative,
objective information about business.
When if you asked me like what is the Wall Street Journal?
That's how I've always thought of them.
So to see the,
see this video pretty shocking isn't it?
Well it is disturbing because there's nothing there.
No it Mike,
the death to all Jews thing.
The fact that city did he pay those guys to hold up that sign like $5 to write
on a sign so he could go oh cause you know cause has to be right.
He's just breaking it to exactly what exactly.
If nobody had said anything,
nothing would come.
It's in poor taste and if you're representing Disney you can't fuck with that
stuff.
That's all that is.
He's been understand shit.
It's not,
my point is I'm defending them.
It's not evidence of antisemitism.
No.
Yeah,
no.
He's just saying something fucked up because he's trying to be shocking.
Yeah.
He's just think that Hitler stuff like,
Holy Shit.
There was nothing there.
Not so stupid.
It's just the stupidest thing in the world.
[inaudible]
okay.